that's not the plan rule 92 3 with the
BET Awards celebrating 50 years of
hip-hop and it's only right there one of
the greatest rappers of all time
Jadakiss is here with his son and his
father yeah Special Special okay so I
saw you guys announce the coffee was it
last year you guys announced it or was
it earlier this year
okay I love coffee all I do is drink
black coffee I don't like no funny [__]
in my [__] I want that [__] raw oh we
got to send it I was gonna say tell me
about the car like what's the idea of my
dad been in coffee for over 40 years so
you're a coffee OG yeah yeah I started
out
working for a large importing company I
actually worked for Maxwell House okay
I've kept some money in a Maxwell House
jar before yeah
hey before the weed jars that's where
you keep your weeds yeah the cans yes
yeah but uh I was importing coffee and
I've been on that side of the business
like I said for 40 years but I thought
that as he got older and as
the hip-hop artists leverage their
notoriety and fame
entrepreneurship you know I mean with
the vodka and the champagne well your
son's a degenerate Gambler so he has to
make up for the the sports gambling with
the coffee business
my me and him begin these my bookie
checks you know what I'm saying
mybookie.ag use my promo code not his
um no I was gonna ask like
are you guys do you watch a Curb Your
Enthusiasm with Larry David
okay so there's this like whole season
that revolves around him opening a
coffee shop
and and how important it is to go and
get the best beans where are y'all
getting the beans from
I can't give you that but we sourced
from Central and South America okay okay
Central and South America okay so you
hopping on the plane you're going over
there my dad gets in the field okay
take him into some coffee see some farms
and train them up the right way I love
it yeah
some sort of idea of how this whole
thing works because I think in order to
produce a good product you need to know
how you got it you know it's it's not
that can of coffee that you open every
morning there's a lot of work that's on
for sure for sure you know we need to
train him up and all that stuff and what
about you man like give me your roll in
the coffee because not a lot of young
people are drinking coffee I mean
they're drinking like smoothies with
caramel and whipped cream no no that's
not coffee I'm out they're drinking like
smoothies they're drinking like
Frappuccinos and [__] oh um
maintaining and getting the youth and
doing all the leg work I gotta like he
said getting hands on I learned how to
roast the coffee at a young age learning
how to taste roasting rappers his whole
life so it's only right
only right I gotta get your guys's
perspective on what it was like to watch
your father put on the most historical
hip-hop moment in the last five to ten
years I beat up put out his list and he
didn't have you on a list that year I've
had you number one just off the I
remember that he was going you went hard
for me yo what was it like watching the
verses from both y'all's perspective
because it was legendary that's when
that really really knew that I'm saying
this this guy is on to something this is
the first one that he did with Fab and
and right uh you know we're coming out
of the pandemic you know we're locked
down he came out of this thing he got
two rings out of the out of the out of
the pandemic yeah and well the second
one was really
yeah but you know and uh you know they
called him the king of verses now
whatever that means but you know he he
showed himself and and like I said
before he's a very competitive guy I
don't know if you know it but you know
he when he gets into something he's he
stays with it so I mean he puts
everything he's got into it so it was a
surprise but then if you think hot
enough it really wasn't a surprise I
wasn't surprised yeah I told her I was
like you guys are crazy I don't think
the locks are winning this what about
you for me I'm one of his biggest fans
oh boy assistant you look just like
himself yo you're probably walking
around Yonkers just getting so much play
be like yeah
no but yeah um I'm one of his biggest
fans old biases inside so this is
argument I have all the time whether it
be Twitter the barbershop anywhere like
so it was what I knew he could do okay
give me your favorite body of work
either solo album a locks album maybe a
champ is here mixtape I don't know
what's your favorite Kiss album
favorite album no just something it's
the first album for the arrogance but
the second album my favorite record on
the second album is bring you down okay
all right
okay we look like we got a Jim Jones
Pusha T battle Brewing
I don't know what you got I don't like
the battle well who you who you picking
if if if the odds are on my bookie
I'm saying Pusha T's minus 700.
I'm not I'm not I'm not really
vying for what's going on with that if
it was a if it was supposed to happen
that's cool but I don't like
it's from the
the sound bites from the interview of it
was my it was my Rap Radar you know what
I mean so or my rap caviar interview it
was it's cool but it ain't cool for me I
don't like the matchup
see I see first of all shout out to Jim
Jim's a Legend
um they both Legends and he's got and
he's got a puncher's chance for sure I
think it's cool because there's no
Street should evolved it to me it feels
like it's always dope when there's no no
extra right it just feels like oh we
might just do some dope records some
dope moments if it stays like that ain't
no
if it's no lines crossed outside of rap
I love it just keep Pops I gotta ask you
uh there was a moment in which your son
went to Philly in the middle of his beef
with Beanie Sigel and did was it
Powerhouse yeah he did Powerhouse okay I
remember yeah this is known as one of
the more Wilder things a rapper has ever
done he went into Philly
let me stop you I was crushing the show
like elf I was murdering it
I don't even know what triggered my mind
to say yo
switching it through the district I mean
they threw everything in the world that
french fries
cheese steaks
the beans dish they throwing stuff at me
then I drop we gonna make it and then
they were they were with you again
they love d block in Philly bro they're
hurting me because I didn't I didn't I
didn't want Philly I need out of all the
things I went through with rappers that
one was like dear to me because Philly's
like my second home for real like you
know what I mean 100 what well listen
the coffee where can people get the
coffee at Kiss Cafe
kofi.com any Shops coming not yet but
we're working on it yeah brick and
mortars uh yeah we're working on a few
words something I learned in the music
business
ownership we want to own it all the way
through you know I mean it's like our
baby so when we're gonna take it slow
where will you be able to control it all
the way to the you know I mean we want
to make sure that whoever is selling it
is giving it the proper attention that
it requires listen send me that the only
coffee I drink I put that [__] right on
the podcast no you got your address
what's up with uh new music I got some
stuff in the works we got locks we've
been working switzen's it's a nice pack
you might get a lock Swiss
that was kind of one of the things that
outaver versus a little sad about we
didn't I felt like the perfect
opportunity to drop people you got to
get the stuff has to be right are you
are you still in depth Channel yeah two
projects I'm I'm knocking them out right
now okay so that's gonna be the next a
ride with me you know what I'd like to
see kids just finishing the contract
straight fans perspective what I would
love to see you just lock in with one
producer do like a 10 pack with The
Alchemist Alvin hitting me too you and
Alchemist 10 tracks me who else yeah you
[__] around me crazy you'll get a
[__] Grammy off that
hey Freddy got nominated up for alfredo
I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take your
advice on that because me and Al gotta
uh uh chemistry of like no one that's
what I'm saying you're an alchemist 10
songs 12 Songs something like that man
um catch real quick before before you go
uh I've always respected your ear
um my guy Millie's is tearing it up
um shots are so raspy
um I'm curious outside of Millie's who
man who who are you a fan of this on the
come up right now oh everybody I like I
like
one thing about me I'll give everybody a
Fed listen you know what I mean because
it's like the NBA some of these dudes
would be better some dudes that get
[__] on now will be better in a year
or two or three years you know I mean so
I try to listen to I like rap though no
I mean I like I like rap
let's see if he's around we like I like
rappers that rap because now you can get
over doing some other things with sides
rapping but and then that rap the J
Cole's
you know the rappers man I like the
rappers also uh you're a sports fanatic
I'm a sports fanatic uh Knicks didn't do
[__] at the trade deadline or at the
draft they never do I was kind of hoping
they would have moved off Randall maybe
go get a try to get Dame or try to I
don't know coming off we're coming off a
good year though you don't want
brunson's amazing we're coming off with
50 more pieces what do you like going
into the new season my son's got Bradley
Beal oh yeah look y'all better win it I
don't want it y'all better at least make
it to the chip if we're going to my
bookie and we're putting it back down
who you better win the championship in
2020 was it four 23 now right now I was
looking I would
I would leave it at Denver or is it even
Denver or Phoenix for me Denver right
now without any freaking repeat
um hey yo I'm gonna this I just met this
guy outside I'm gonna just have hey spit
16 for kiss real quick mark
he said he likes real rap you say you
like right that's what he said I said
he's so sharp but he's so foolish and yo
we're fine number one every year bet you
I'm close to it these other
[__] not live the only [__] in
your top five that'll get your top five
men I'm trying to figure it out I ain't
want a different route hardest rap in
the city sleeping on the [__] couch I
was working gig after gig before I hit
the clout staying with my old [__]
trying to figure dinner out telling
[__] at the job fair I'm the lso yeah
yeah grab a clipboard and fill us out
the rap game imma tear into I put my
whole life on the line then banked on a
miracle like one day when I make the top
greats we gonna laugh about on the days
that I take writing Rhymes and getting
blazed in my place when I was trading
dick for braids and hot plates we in
Arizona ain't no blueprint for the [__]
just a bunch of critics with a two cents
in this [__] I'm meant for this [__]
plug cities What's Happening Now lapping
them now some we litter than trash on
the ground yo it seemed like the same
demographic that I debate with dudes
that let life pass them up in the Matrix
once it has been since they had it
running and Faded half the [__] just
hating his rapping that it naked mad
cause the European mink on me they ain't
gonna keep never put a ring on she they
gonna see the links on freeze cause I'm
getting paid by the ball like drinks on
me [__]
all right all right we need more of that
man murkers that was a kiss that's what
I appreciate it we need more of that
Miracles
Real Talk hey kiss I appreciate you
brother hey it's good to meet you man
pops good to meet you I can look forward
to [__] up some of that coffee man